البنك الدولي يقول انه سيجري تقييما سريعا
للاضرار والاحتياجات بعد تدمير سد نوفا
السعوديه تدين تخريب مبنى سفارتها
وملحقيتها بالسودان وترفض كل اشكال العنف
تجاه البعثات الدبلوماسيه
محامنا فيدراليون يخطرون ترامب كتابيا
بانه يخضع لتحقيق جنائي بشان تخزين وثائق
سريه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر اعلن
البنك الدولي انه سيجري تقييما سريعا
للاضرار والاحتياجات عقب تدمير سد نوفاك
خوفكا اقلت مديره عمليات البنك ان بردري
في تغريده لها ان تدمير السد له عواقب
وخيمه للغايه على الخدمات الاساسيه
والبيئيه وتوليد الطاقه
اعلن الرئيس الفرنسي والمكرونه بلاده
سترسل في غضون ساعات مساعدات لتلبيه
الاحتياجات العاجله لاوكرانيا بعد التفجير
الذي استهدف اسد نوفا كخوفكا وكتب ماكرون
على تويتر بعد مكالمه هاتفيه مع نظيره
الاوكراني
انه اعرب للرئيسكي عن تضامنه مع الشعب
الاوكراني وان فرنسا تدين هذا العامل
الشنيع الذي يعرض السكان للخطر
في الاثناء ما زال المسؤولون من الجانبين
الروسي والاوكرانيه ترشقون تهمه تفجير
السد فقد وصف سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي
تدمير سد نوفاك خوفك بانه هجوم ارهابي
خططت له كياب بتنسيق مع الدول الغربيه
في اليوم السابق تم اجراء تصريف واسع
النطاق للمياه في محطه الطاقه الكهرومائيه
الواقعه في اعلى النهر ثم تمت مهاجمتك
خوفكا والتي تسببت مسبقا في عواقب اكثر
ضررا من الفيضان يدرك نظام كييف جيدا
الخطر الذي يتعرض له السكان بسبب فيضان
اراضي منطقه خيرسون والتهديد الذي تتعرض
له محطه زابوريا للطاقه النوويه
في المقابل وصف رئيسه مجلس الامن القومي
والدفاع الاوكراني اوليكسي دانيلوف
الاتهامات الروسيه بتورط اوكرانيا في
تدمير السد بالامر السخيف مؤكدا ان الجيش
الاوكراني لم يكن متواجدا في المنطقه وقت
حادث تدمير
الاتهامات باننا وراء تدمير السد امر
مستحيل فعليا في ذلك الوقت لم يكن جيشنا
ولا مواطننا متواجدين في المنطقه للاسف
الشديد تم احتلال المنطقه منذ مايو الماضي
من قبل الروس لذا فان القول باننا فعلنا
ذلك في وجودهم هو امر سخيف
من جانبها قالت نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني هنا مليار ان التفجير سد كخوفك
ادى الى تدمير مواقع عسكريه روسيه
واضافت بان روسيا تسببت في اضرار كبيره
لقواتها بتفجيرها للسد وبحسب نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني فان السير الناتج عن
تدمير السد ادى الى الانجراف في الال غام
الى مناطق القوات الروسيه في خرسون بعد
تفجيره
[موسيقى]
ما تزال اثار تدمير سد نوفا كخوفكا جليه
على المدن المجاوره مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر وصل الى موقع السد ورصد لنا بعض من
الاثار الناجمه عن تفجيره
المشهد هنا في مدينه نوفيك خوفا 7 مفقودين
الحديث عن الاف
المواطنين الذين تم اجلائهم الحديث عن
انقاذ العشرات من فوق اسطح المنازل كانت
المياه تصل الى مستوى اعلى من هذا الذي
وصلت اليه اليوم بكثير لكن اليوم مختلف
وما زالت العمليات
مستمره لاجلاء المواطنين من هذه المناطق
[موسيقى]
من داخل هذا المنزل ننقل لكم ارتفاع منسوب
المياه كما نرى حيث في مدينه نوفاكا خوفكا
تضرر المدنيين بشكل كبير لقناتي العربيه
والحدث رائد الاغبر نوفا
هذا ولم تكتمر 24 ساعه على التفجير الذي
دمر سد نوفاك خوفكا حتى وقع تفجير جديد
طلع هذه المره خطه تصدير الامونيا بين
مدينتي توليتي واوداسا في مقاطعه وانتشرت
صور تظهر حجم الضرر والتسرب الناتج عن
التفجيد الذي وصفته وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
بالعمل التخريبي
في حوالي الساعه التاسعه مساء بتوقيت
موسكو فجرت مجموعه استطلاع الاوكرانيه خط
انابيب بتولياتي للامونيا بالقرب من منطقه
خاركيف ونتيجه لهذا العمل الارهابي وقعت
اصابات في صفوف السكان المدنيين وقد تم
تزويدهم بالمساعده الطبيه اللازمه وفي
الوقت الحالي يتم تصريف بقايا الامونيا من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه عبر الاجزاء المتضرره
من خط الانابيب
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه روسيه ماريا
خروفا قالت في بين لها ان اصلاح خط انابيب
الامامي الذي تم تفجيره في منطقه سيستغرق
من شهر الى ثلاثه اشهر
وفقا للمعلومات المتاحه في الخامس من
يونيو تم تفجير خط انابيب الامونيا
في منطقه خاضعه لسيطره اوكرانيا نعم انها
نفس منشاه البنيه التحتيه المدنيه التي تم
ذكرها مرارا وتكرارا كجزء من اتفاق حبوب
البحر الاسود وبسبب استهدافها تم اخراج
احدى محطات الضخ من الخدمه وتشغيل صمامات
الاغلاق ومع ذلك تسربت المواد الخام وفقا
لتقييم الاولي ستستغرق اعمال السياره
والاصلاح ما يقرب من شهر الى ثلاثه اشهر
قال الكريم ان الرئيس الروسي بحث هاتفيا
مع ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان بلفه اسواق الطاقه العالميه وسبل
استقرارها كما اوضح الكرمل انا بوتين
والامير محمد بن سلمان ثمان تعاون في اطار
اوبك بلس كما ناقش بناء العلاقات التجاريه
والاقتصاديه والمشاريع في مجالات
الاستثمار والطاقه
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه عن ادانه
المملكه باشد العبارات ما قامت به جماعات
مسلحه من تخريب وعبث في مبنى السفاره
السعوديه
وملحقيتها لدى السودان اضافه الى تخريب
سكني وممتلكات الموظفين السعوديين
العاملين في السفاره وعربه الخارجيه
السعوديه في بيان رفض المملكه التام لكل
اشكال العنف والتخريب باتجاه البعثات
والممثليات الدبلوماسيه واكدت السعوديه
اهميه التصدي لهذه الجماعات المسلحه التي
تحاول النيله من عوده الامن والاستقرار
للسودان وشعبه
وكانت الخارجيه السودانيه اعلنت ان قوات
الدعم السريعه اقتحمت سفارات الصين
وفلسطين ومنزل السفير العماني واتهمت
الوزاره الدعم السريع بسرقه سيارات سيارات
دبلوماسيه من السفاره الصينيه والعبث
بمستنداتها وتعذيب عدد من عمال السفاره
الفلسطينيه
ميدانيا تواصلت الاشتباكات العنيفه بين
قوات الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
وسط استمرار تحليق الطيران الحربي في
العاصمه الخرطوم ووصل الاقتتال هذه المره
الى منطقه مجمع اليرموك وهو وهي احدى
شركات التصنيع الحربي التابعه للجيش في
جنوب مدينه الخرطوم كما امتدت الاشتباكات
الى مستودع الشجره الذي يعد ثاني اكبر
مستودع بالعاصمه السودانيه للغازي والمواد
البتروليه
[موسيقى]
يبدو ان الحرب المتواصله في السودان بدات
تاخذ منعطفا جديدا من خلال استخدام اسلحه
النوويه الكلام منسوب هنا للمتحدث باسم
قوى الحريه والتغيير ياسر عرمان الذي غرض
بالقول ان الحرب تشهد مع اعتبره تغيرا
نوعيا باستخدام الاسلحه الثقيله والمدفعيه
البعيده المدى في مناطق ماهوله بالسكان
عرمان ذكر ان هناك تصاعدا ايضا في وتيره
الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
مشيرا الى ان ذلك من شانه ان يزيد عدد
الضحايا والمدنيين ويدمر البنيه التحتيه
وعبر المتحدث باسم قوى الحريه والتغيير عم
خوفه من ان يطرح من وصفهم سلول النظام
السابق فكره تقسيم السودان كحل للازمه في
البلاد وهو ما سيدمر السودان على حده
تعبيره
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
تونس تنتشر جثث مهاجرين افارقه غرقوا
قباله السواحل الموسير وايطاليا تنقذ اكثر
من 1400 مهاجر
اهلا بكم من جديد ابلغ المدعون العامون
الامريكيون الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
بفتح تحقيق جنائي ضده حسب ما افادت به
صحيفه بوليتيكو
وقالت قناه اي بي سي نيوز ان تحقيق مرتبط
بتخزين وثائق سريه ونشر ترامب في وقت سابق
على شبكه
الاجتماعيه رساله تفيد بان احدا لم يبلغه
بالتهم الموجهه اليه وانه لم يرتكب اي
اخطاء كانت صحيفه واشنطن بوست ذكرت ان
محامي الرئيس السابق ناقش قضيه التعامل
غير السليم مع الاوراق السريه في وزاره
العدل
قدم نائب الرئيس الامريكي السابق مايك
بينس اوراقه رسميا للانضمام الى قائمه
مرشحي الحزب الجمهوري للرئاسه لعام 2024
ومن المقرر ان يطلق بنس حملته رسميا في
ولايه ايوا وهي الولايه الاولى التي ستدلي
باصواتها في ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري
[موسيقى]
يطرح نفسه كزعيم لمدرسه رونالد ريجن
التقليديه مسلحا بمبادئ الحزب المحافظه
استراتيجيته تعتمد على مهاجمه الرئيس
بايدن لكن نائب الرئيس السابق لا يذكر اسم
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب في اعلانه
الترشح لانتخابات الرئاسه ويطلق حملته
الانتخابيه من ولايه ايوا التي تعتبر نقطه
الانطلاق نحو البيت الابيض
ايوه هي المكان الذي شكلنا فيه قيادتنا
المحافظه ايا وهي الولايه التي تحدد معالم
مرشح الانتخابات ويجب ان اخبركم انه خلال
العامين الماضيين امضينا انا وكارن الكثير
من الوقت في التفكير والصلاه بشان كل ما
يواجه بلدنا وما يمكننا فعله للخدمه نائب
الرئيس السابق ينضم رسميا الى عدد من
الجمهوريين الذين يتحدون رئيسهم السابق
مثل نيكي هيلي حاكمه ولايه السابقه وكريس
كريستي حاكم ولايه نيوجيرسي السابق
الجمهوريه الوحيد الذي ينحدر من اصول
افريقيه لكن التحدي الحقيقي للرئيس ترامب
ياتي من حاكم فلوريدا
انا متاكد من ان ترامب يفكر كالتالي انا
من صنع مايك بينس فقد كان حاكم ولايه
للمره الثانيه ولم يسمع به احد من قبل لكن
اي شكر حصلت عليه منه لم يقبل بانس بتجاوز
دستور الولايات المتحده في السادس من
يناير والان هذا الرجل يترشح للانتخابات
ضدي
جميع المرشحين يجربون حدودهم ويعرضون
اشدتهم المحافظه اجتماعيا وماليا ويهاجمون
الرئيس بايدن ويعتبرونه فاشلا في انقاذ
الاقتصاد وترد القيم الاجتماعيه ببعيد
لكن البعض يرى ان العدد المتزايد للمرشحين
سيعطي افضليه للرئيس ترامب حيث ستتوزع
الاصوات بينهم ويصبح هو الفائز والبعض
الاخر يرى ان مشاكل ترامب القانونيه قد
تمنعه من الترشح في النهايه
حتى الان
حاكم ولايه نيوجيرسي السابق هو الوحيد بين
المرشحين الجمهوريين الذي بدا يهاجم
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب بشكل جديد هذا
قد لا يؤثر في القاعده المخلصه الشعبيه
التي بقت وفيه للرئيس ترامب لكنه قد يؤثر
في النهايه في شريحه معينه من الحزب
الجمهوري التي لا تريد ان يكون ترامب هو
مرشح للحزب الجمهوري ناديه البيبيسي
العربيه
انتشل خبر السواحل التونسي تسعه جثث
مهاجرين افارقه فيما انقذ 29 اخرين بعد
غرق قريبهم قبلت سواحل المونسير اثناء
محاولتهم الوصول الى الساحل الايطالي
واعلن خبر السواحل ان عمليات البحث ما
زالت جاريه عن المزيد من الغرق المحتملين
في عدد من القوارب الاخرى المتجهه الى
ايطاليا
كما ان الخفر السواحل الايطاليه انه تم
انقاذ اكثر من
1400 مهاجر من قوارب مكتظه خلال اربعه
عمليات منفصله في البحر قباله جنوب
ايطاليا واشترى البيان الى انه كان هناك
سبعه
واربعين مهاجرا بينهم طفلان بحاجه للرعايه
الطبيه وتابع البيان بان احدى السفن سفن
حرس السواحل نقلت حوالي 600 مهاجر من على
متنقارب ثم جلبت بعده وذلك نحو 650 من
قارب صعيد اخر
قررت اداره الطيران الفيدرالي الامريكي
توقيف رحلات جويه الى مدينه نيويورك بسبب
ضعف الرؤيه
بالناتجه عن حرائق الغابات وقالت اداره
طيران ان الرحلات الجويه المتجهه الى مطار
نيويورك اما توقفت مؤقتا او تاخرت عن موعد
وصولها فيما غطى دخان الحرائق سماء
نيويورك ومبنى الامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
يشكك الديمقراطيون في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي بامتثال تويتر لمعايير الخصوصيه
منذ استحواذ ايلون ماسك عليه وارسل اربعه
اعضاء رساله الى ماسك والرئيس التنفيذي
القادم طالبوهم فيها بالرد على اسئله حول
التزامات المنصه وتاثير التسريحات
والاستقالات على قدرتها على الامتثال في
المقابل يرى الجمهورينا في الكونغرس ان
تحقيقات الديمقراطيين مع تويتر تهدف الى
مضايقه ايلون ماسك
امتثال تويتر لمعايير الخصوصيه يزيد
السجاله في الكونغرس الامريكيه حيث يتساءل
مشرعون حول ما اذا كانت المنصه تحت اشراف
ايلون ماسك قد انتهكت قوانين حمايه
المستهلك وبياناته بعد عمليات تسريح
واستقالات واسعه ما قد يعرضها مع صاحبها
لمخاطر قانونيه هائله اربعه اعضاء
ديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ هم اليزابيث
عبروا عن قلقهم بشان امتثال تويتر
بالتزامات لجنه التجاره الفيدراليه اثر
رحيل الرئيس السابق لقسم الثقه والامان
منه واعتبروا ان سلوك ماسك يكشف لا مبالاه
واضحه تجاه التزامات المنصه القانونيه وهو
مصدر قلق حسب ما صرح لنا السيناتور
الديمقراطي تمكين
مقارنه مع ما فعلوه بالقوانين التي
ينتهكونها يجب توضيح ما يحدث ان محبط حقا
من جوده القياده التي قدمها ماسك لهذه
المنصه التي يستخدمها الجميع وكما تعلم
اعتقد انه سيرغب في ان تكون منصه موثوقه
لكن بدلا من ذلك يجعل الامر اقل ثقه به كل
يوم من الواضح انه مصدر قلق تويتر يخضع
حاليا لتحقيق من قبل لجنه التجاره
الفيدراليه بشان انتهاكات محتمله مرتبطه
بعدم تطبيقه سياسات امن بيانات فعاله
معرضه لاختراق جواسيس اجانب لكن مشرعين
جمهوريين اعتبروا ان تحقيق لجنه التجاره
الفيدراليه يهدف الى مضايقه ماسك ويمثل
مثالا على ما يعرف بتسليح الحكومه
الامريكيه ويثير الشك وفق تصريحات خاصه
بنا للسيناتور الجمهوري جوشولي
يبدو انه مستهدف جدا بالنسبه لي اعني ما
يخلقني ان لجنه التجاره الفيدراليه عن
التحقيق وقد تكون على حق بعد ان طالب كل
الديمقراطيين هنا بذلك وبداوا باستخدام
هذه اللغه حول الانتهاكات القانونيه ضد
ماسك اعني ما يدهشني كيف ان بعض زملاء
الديمقراطيين مع احترامي لهم مناهضون
لحريه التعبير
ومن الامور التي يسال المشرعون
الديمقراطيون عنها تقييم للخصوصيه والامان
لخدمه العلامه الزرقاء وعما اذا كانت
تويتر احتفظ ببرنامج شامل للامن السيبراني
لحمايه بيانات المستخدم منذ استحواذ ماسك
عليه حسين الطاوض العربيه واشنطن
اعلنا رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريجيسونا
خلال زيارته الى واشنطن ان المملكه
المتحده ستستضيف هذا العام اول قمه عالميه
للذكاء الاصطناعي في محاوله للتوصل الى
مقاربه مشتركه للدول للحد من المخاطر
المتصله بالتقنيه الحديثه وقال سونا قبيله
محادثات مع رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في
البيت الابيض على مر تاريخ اخترعنا تقنيات
ثوريه حديثه وقمنا بتسخييرها لصالح خير
البشريه وهذا ما علينا القيام به مجددا
انتهى اليوم الثالث لمحاكمه العصر التي
يخوضها الامير هاري ضد مجموعه صحف ميرور
حيث ادلى الامير بافادته لليوم الثاني على
التوالي في استجواب استمر اكثر من ثمان
ساعات محتدمه خاض فيها محامي الدفاع في
تفاصيل 33 مقاله اخباريه استند اليها هاري
في رفع قضيته ثلاث وثلاثون مقاله اخباريه
يستند اليها هاري في شهادته ضد مجموعه
صحفي مرر يقول ان فيها معلومات من
المستحيل ان يكون قد حصل عليها الصحفيون
من دون تجسس عليه وعلى المقربين منه فهاري
في مهمه ليس فقط لتغيير المشهد الاعلامي
وانما لمحاسبه المسؤولين عن معاناته في
علاقاته السابقه وفي معاناه والدته
[موسيقى]
المحامي المرموق اندروغرين لم يرحم هذه في
جلسه استمرت اكثر من ثمان ساعات على مدار
يومين دخل في تفاصيل المقالات معلومه تلو
الاخرى اتعبت الامير الذي بدا عليه
الانزعاج احيانا رغم ربطت شاشه بشكل عام
بالنسبه لمحامي الدفاع ادعاءات هاري تستند
تكهنات وليس لمعلومات وادله كافيه
[موسيقى]
احب الرجل لكنني لست مهتما حقيقه بالموضوع
انا احاول مواصله حياتي اتمنى له كل
التوفيق لكن لاكون صادقا لا اتابع الموضوع
لانه اصبح لدينا الكثير من الاخبار حول
هاري
اعتقد انه يتم اعطاء الموضوع اهتماما اكبر
من حجمه اعي انه يريد خصوصيته لكنه بعد
ذلك عندما قرر ترك العائله الملكيه
والذهاب الى الخارج وبالتالي هو يحصل على
ما يعطى له
[موسيقى]
الاعلاميه كونه كان رئيس التحرير في ديل
ميري وقت نشر المقالات المشار اليها والذي
تردد اسمه مرارا فالقضيه كان له تعليق
ساخر
فتطلع الى قراءه حملته الخاصه في كتابه
القادم وليس من المتوقع ان يعلق قصر
باكنهم على القضيه التي تتعلق باحد افراد
العائله الملكيه علما ان شعارها المشهور
لا تتذمر ابدا ولا تشرح ابدا من لندن عروب
عبد الحق العربيه
في نهايه شهاده تذكير بابرز عناوينها
البنك الدولي يقول انه سيجري تقييما سريعا
للاضرار والاحتياجات بعد تدمير سد نوفا
السعوديه تدين تخريب مبنى سفارتها
وملحقيتها بالسودان وترفض كل اشكال العنف
تجاه البعثات الدبلوماسيه
محامونا فيدراليون يخطرون ترامب كتابيا
بانه يخضع لتحقيق جنائي بشان تخزين وثائق
سريه
الى اللقاء عند المنتصف
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات